Sal gubernale has been posting his own
duet videos online do you know anything
about this
evidently what this is is some sort of
uh situation on Tick Tock where people
put up a song
where they're singing one part
and you're allowed to sing with them and
then you're supposed to post here is Sal
singing Elvis Presley's Love Me Tender
with a stranger on Tick Tock complete
[Music]
and I love you so much
[Music]
for my darling I love you I said who are
you salvis and he goes oh that's funny
no seriously do you think you're a good
singer honestly do you I like I you know
I posted I don't know yeah I like to I
like I like to sing too but I'm not
posting me singing Because I know I'm
bad you know what I mean yeah but Howard
I didn't really post that to the public
my Tick Tock I don't promote my Tick
Tock I've never told anyone about my
Tick Tock I've never created links but I
just but why would you put that out
there then let's say even if how many
people follow you on tick tock not even
I think a thousand because I never told
anyone but I wanted people to see it who
don't know me I just wanted to have a
but who doesn't know you that out of
these thousand people what are you
talking about I don't mean to punch
holes in this but more of his great
thoughts I want it to be seen by people
who don't know me so my thousand
followers will see it you think you're
good here's South singing Can't Help
Falling in Love
that's not Sal he's coming up
there we go
[Music]
and then the vibrato is that oh
are you are you thinking you sound like
Elvis because you sound like you're
imitating out it's my tribute to Elvis I
love singing no no it's not a tribute
quiet you